hallo liebe freunde willkommen zurück
bei esi german wir sind wieder auf der
straße hier in berlin für euch und wir
wollen heute mit menschen in deutschland
über tabuthemen reden welche tabu themen
gibt es in deutschland über wasser redet
man nicht mit anderen menschen oder was
ist vielleicht ein unangenehmes thema
das werden wir heute mal versuchen
rauszufinden auf wunsch von euch und ja
gehen wir los
[Musik]
unser thema ist heute tabu themen in
deutschland gibt es da welche die mal
solche nein ich glaube so ein bisschen
anders als vor zehn zwanzig jahren also
erst mal darf man glaube ich über alles
spricht ja ach du schande wirklich tabus
oder fragt ihr aber was gutes thema mit
dem man gerne mit fremden auf der straße
varese er gesehen teil das sind dann so
was jetzt heraus die wir sind wir sind
liberal also es keine tabus nicht
wahrscheinlich nicht und haben ja also
nicht was die leute über themen reden
über die man nicht reden würde sondern
eher so dass man selber irgendwie über
themen reden die leute erstmal okay aber
auch so schon auch über politik aber
auch in die über was auch immer eigene
erfahrungen oder tod oder drogen ist
also ganz viele von diesen themen die
man irgendwie eigentlich vielleicht
nicht so mit irgendwelchen leuten
geredet was ich schon mache also ich
empfinde es nicht so dass es in
deutschland wirklich tabu themen gibt es
wird natürlich oftmals noch über die
vergangenheit in bestimmten dingen nicht
gerne darüber gesprochen ob das jetzt
bestimmte ddr vergangenheit ist oder
aber auch aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
werden bestimmte themen nicht sehr gerne
aufgegriffen weil man sich natürlich
auch etwas verstricken kann drin aber
eigentlich ist es schon so dass wir
reden können über alles und und es auch
nicht den mut den mund verbieten lassen
aber ich glaube dass es eine generation
geschichte ist also die älteren leute
wen teilweise über manche themen nicht
so zum beispiel über den zweiten
weltkrieg wir gegen leute wegen schon
eher über alles mögliche hat
ich denke das ist eine generation sache
ist ich denke in deutschland wird immer
noch wenig zum beispiel war gehalt
konkret mit arbeitskollegen geredet das
ist immer noch ein tabuthema zumindest
in gewissen kreisen
ja es kommt nur darauf an welche
gesellschaftlichen schicht die leute
sind
jeder hat da so seine tabu-themen aber
so groß große tabus haben wir glaube ich
nicht mehr große tabuthema also wir
können theoretisch über alles reden
theoretisch ob es dann machen ich
persönlich würde auch über private dinge
nicht so viel mit es nur begrenzt und
nur mit bestimmten ausgewählten kollegen
aber nicht irgendwie beim mittagstisch
sexismus ist auf jeden fall ein
tabuthema fangen wir mal so an ich
glaube solche sachen wie depression
emotionen und so weiter und so fort wird
auch nicht so viel darüber gesprochen
was du noch geld wahrscheinlich über
geld in deutschland freunde familie also
ich glaube dass unter kollegen so ein
bisschen tabuthema aufgrund dessen dass
die hierarchien unternehmen natürlich
sehr strikt dürften deswegen sollte man
da ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
tabuthemen das geld ist das in
deutschland warum redet man nicht gerne
was geld man heute ist aber man bildete
eben nicht darüber oder man hat es nicht
gibt s nicht zu ein gehalt das gehalt
treten ist gesprochen ja nur mit
arbeitskollegen oder auch in der familie
mit sehr wenig menschen da so wenig
menschen reden mit mir über das was sie
verdienen
[Gelächter]
es hat ja mal was gutes und was schlecht
dass manchmal das was gutes wenn man es
nicht weiß ja manchmal würde man sich
gerne messen wollen
mit kollegen wo man denkt warum kriegt
er jetzt mehr oder nicht das ist etwas
was deutsche vielleicht nicht so gerne
machen
nicht in der beziehung da versteht tages
relativ so dass jeder so ein kleiner
andere position hatte und wenn man
glaube ich da ich offen mein gott du
verdienst mehr als ich irgendwie warum
wieso weshalb ich glaube das kann sehr
schnell zu unfrieden innerhalb der
arbeitsstelle sorgen derweil die
gehälter nicht gerecht und gleich
verteilt sind
das heißt jeder hat er seinen eigenen
liedern laufen denke ich tabuthemen in
deutschland gibt es da welche wir haben
darüber gesprochen vergewaltigung ja
weil wir waren letzte woche in dem film
geht es darum dass eine frau
vergewaltigt wird und aber quasi das gut
findet und dann die opferrolle abgibt
und an den mann gibt und eklig da nicht
mehr das was er will dass er das nicht
mehr gut findet wenn sie kein opfer mehr
ist und das ist ein tabu thema da schon
ich würde sagen schon ja es ist
natürlich eine herausforderung auf der
straße mit fremden menschen über
tabuthemen zu sprechen
ich habe mich ja mal ein bisschen
vorbereitet politik wikipedia sagt zum
beispiel zum thema tabu themen in
deutschland gehalt verdienst bzw
eigentum kinderlosigkeit tod bestimmte
fragen der gesundheit zum beispiel
blasenschwäche depression oder
brustkrebs aber auch häusliche gewalt
kaufsucht analphabetismus
ausländerkriminalität und insolvenz sind
tabuthemen in deutschland nicht tabu
hingegen sind politik religion und
geschäft was ich ganz interessant fand
natürlich kann man auf der straße nicht
mit jedem direkt über schwierige themen
sprechen das sind natürlich auch
manchmal sehr persönliche themen wie
krankheiten
aber wir hören uns mal weiter um ich
hatte ja als allererstes an hitler
gedacht hat mich weil ich das gefühl
habe im ausland egal wo man ist sind die
leute viel offener damit und machen
witze darüber und so weiter und hier ist
es ja ich würde ich sagen tabuthema aber
auf jeden fall ernst
ja es stimmt dass man auch dann kommen
freunde aus polen die machen dann einen
hitler witz und die deutschen sind dann
die lachen natürlich berührt und gibt es
noch irgendwas über das man so mit der
familie nicht redet oder in bestimmten
situationen ich rede politik in
bestimmten punkten denke ich gerade wenn
familie und freunde in eine andere
politische meinung haben
das thema vielleicht ja so unter
gleichgesinnten in anführungszeichen
angesprochen als wenn sie freunden sich
davor hätten könnten eine familie
freundeskreis ist nicht unbedingt sehr
erfreulich sage ich jetzt mal reden sie
mit arbeitskollegen zum beispiel darüber
was sie wählen und mit freunden ja das
wird erklärt das muss auf den tisch und
ihre richtung muss da beleuchtet sein
den leuten erzählen was wir die letzten
mal gewählt haben ja heute einigen
jahren will die piraten gewählt weil ich
dachte da passiert und was ganz wunder
verlust man muss ja auch mal ein
bisschen nach vorne blicken hat sich
nicht bewährt
fehlen wird dann noch zugegeben ja klar
wisst ihr das so von euren familien was
die da alle so wählen
ja ja ich tatsächlich nicht
also ich glaube ich das mal von mir
ansprechen würde ich glaube ich würde
erstmal zu großen heftigen diskussionen
führen werden damit die und danach
wissen würden was wahrscheinlich wählen
würden das ist es möglich schon meine
familie dass er für frieden sorgen
sie sparen das thema eher so aus und dem
burgfrieden zu genau so ist es gekommen
genau das ist gibt es irgendwas über das
ihr mit euren eltern nicht vielleicht so
kinder erfahrungen oder so also
sexualität im allgemeinen ja also mit
eltern nicht so ich dachte dass
vielleicht davon weiß nicht ich stehe
also ja das war sie schon unsere folge
zum tabu themen in deutschland werden
über einige themen gesprochen auf der
straße um einige sachen gehört aber
vielleicht auch noch nicht alles gehört
sind ja schließlich tabuthemen deshalb
wollen wir jetzt von euch wissen was
kennt ihr filter wo themen in euren
ländern also was gibt es in euren
ländern über das ihr nicht so gut
sprechen können mit freunden mit familie
mit arbeitskollegen und was habt ihr
vielleicht auch in deutschland kennen
gelernt wenn ihr in deutschland lebt
oder hierhin gekommen seid euch was
aufgefallen aber dass die deutschen gar
nicht gerne reden
das wollen wir unbedingt von euch wissen
diskutiert mit uns hier in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr lust habt noch übungen zu
bekommen zu dieser episode oder die
texte zu bekommen und weitere weiteres
videomaterial dann werdet unbedingt
einen patch mit uns paefgen ist die
möglichkeit unser projekt zu finanzieren
und uns zu helfen mit easy german
weiterzumachen
das könne wie gesagt hier werden danke
schön dass ihr da wart und bis zur
nächsten woche